i feel like we're learning a lot but i
also think that there's some people that
are because i'm one of them that's like
way over my head right now here bro
straight up
um so let's bring this down to just
regular people out there most people are
most people i say this all the time i i
gravitate towards personal finance
that's what i care about make your money
save that money invest that money yadda
yadda yep um
talk to the regular people out there the
nine to fivers they're making 50 grand a
year 100 granny or whatever is going on
they're getting their paycheck you know
they're putting their money in their
401k they're renting they have a
mortgage they've got kids yada yada
freaking yada and then you're like bitty
bop and beatty [ __ ] and bit it out and
betty boop
blockchain it's like pump the brakes for
a second bro sure how does this affect
the regular person the regular person
can't afford bitcoin maybe they're
buying some dogecoin and praying maybe
they're buying some fractionalized
shares of bitcoin maybe they're like
look bro i see what's going on nft
like you know you're familiar with like
jumped a shark i had a buddy out there
that all he does is smoke blunts every
single day he hit me up he's like bro
what's up with these nfts i was like
that's it i'm out
okay
my question to you is bring this back to
the normal person why should they even
give a [ __ ] about what you're saying i
don't mean that disrespectfully but
they're just like look bro
i just want to make my money i want to
save some money i want to live my life
you're talking about nodes and nerds and
this and that
just break this down for the regular
person out there
what should they be aware of
what should they be most most concerned
about and just break that down
the first thing is that dollars are a
tool for oppression it's it's bait
it's it's sell your time for this you
can't get the time back but you will get
these dollars
and people do that people work the nine
to five and they're commuting an hour
each way and and having their kids and
doing it 99 of people not just this is a
regular pay everybody does that yes it's
essentially everybody yeah
but those dollars are losing value as
they're sitting in your bank account
mm-hmm inflation's killing our ability
to purchase things you know now a year
ago inflation's not a thing now it's
inflation might be good and here's why
you know and so this is something that
we are we're just total gaslighting by
the way what they're doing they're
saying inflation is good i mean they're
just trying to get middle america to say
okay it's not a big deal right yeah i
mean you've been talking about inflation
for six months man i mean you called it
when janet yeah leland was like it's
only one percent you're like rolling
your eyes it's a mess four years it's a
major six point two percent it's a major
usually two to three percent so it's
double what it usually is it's to make
us rely on them
what what bitcoin does fundamentally is
it gives us tools that allows me to do
business with someone in south carolina
as easily as i can do business with
someone in south korea
and it makes it that i can bootstrap a
business i can be a fintech startup with
a trivial amount of capital as opposed
to
all right i need to write a thing i need
to go to some silicon valley venture
capital and like there's a whole this
whole process that's not the regular
person out there remember we're talking
to regular people here right now silicon
valley capitalist but that's what i'm
saying is that that's the silo that's
the silo that a regular person can't
ever broach they can't get there okay
but with bitcoin
excuse me with bitcoin you have the
ability to create things of value
in an hour's time on your own computer
and sell these things for real value you
can do business on the bitcoin network
much the same way that that the internet
allowed people to maybe create a an ebay
business on the side 15 years ago right
like oh wow i've got extra income
because i figured out that i can go buy
you know designer shoes at the resale
shop and then sell them for 10x what i
bought them for right that was a
revolutionary little thing that the
internet created for people but bitcoin
is that much better because you can do
it with digital assets you can tokenize
your own
your own home your own life future is on
your own uh ability to earn things like
that it gives financial instruments that
have been
kept away from people
forever and it allows them to be in the
hands of people to
do micro lending let's say maybe you've
got 50 grand that you've saved up
because you've you know kept the bank
account for
30 years working at your job
well that 50 grand how can you make that
50 grand work for you you can leave it
uh
that ira or whatever the thing is
i probably get allergies here but with
bitcoin
it allows you to do
uh micro this defy thing like it allows
people to give i'm gonna give a micro
loan i'm gonna choose the interest rate
i'm gonna i'm gonna allow people to drop
some tissue please
appreciate it so i'm i'm i'm going to be
a lender in my neighborhood now and the
on-chain attestation of my identity and
my reputation makes it that people can
trust me we can have a smart contract
secure it and do the escrow and take
away all of the nonsense the stuff that
people don't want to know and hear and
say look you can earn six percent on
your dollar now by lending two people
and i literally think that gerard what i
was telling you right yeah you want to
tell us what you do no okay
because it's illegal have some tissues
thank you no and uh you get very
emotional
let me tell you let me let me let me
let me he was fine for the comments
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]